Rebecca Ford so you're here to tell us
about warframe - yes the sequel what are
you a minutes real yeah I mean I think
there's no no stop so I want what I want
to talk about first is what you learn
from 2019 kind of like yeah you brought
something I brought you back and
everything lessons I want to see like
what you learn from 2019 and without
like as much as you can talk about what
your goals are as a team like Digital
Extremes or maybe even you personally
going into 2020 okay
the first starting with 2019 in general
how-how'd the year ago for warframe like
what were some things that were
touchstones for the game it was the
weirdest year for me personally with
warframe as well as just the game
overall of like identity searching about
building foundations versus just adding
I think you know our last step stream of
the year would have been under a month
ago like December 20th we sat down real
okay thanks through the year here's what
we did here's what we're gonna do
Imperium had launched all that stuff's
there wasn't really like a huge focus on
retrospect which we don't often do so
this is kind of the first retrospective
conversation I've had with cameras on
South Lake a lots happening it's like
Russian a rush of rush of thoughts and
emotion but you know for those streams
you always have to kind of prepare like
what did we actually do in 2019 so like
when you list everything you're like
okay we did a lot but how did it do and
how did it make people feel and what did
they enjoy and what did they not enjoy
and it's I think for 2019 because it was
following as numbers work 2018 like 2018
was this like rush of holy [ __ ] moments
for warframe it was the biggest 10
dokkan it had the wow factor with rail
jack we released in open world and then
2019 shows up and it's basically adding
to that open world and then setting the
expectation that we have to do real Jack
in the new war and in 2019 you have like
a competitive landscape for us that
you've never had before so you all you
the games coming out there like warframe
or kind of like warframe so I'm going
free-to-play so you have all the
attention on like okay well now it's
time to really see what you can do and
we did what we always do which is we
remastered stuff we released new
warframes release bosses
had another 10 Oh Khan but we didn't do
a huge quest really and rail jack came
out and it was just the beginning of
rail jack so it's like we started
something new but we didn't deliver
anything colossal that people I think
I'm coming used to in terms of double
open years open worlds back to back I
should say yes over Al Jack now empyrion
mmm-hmm how is that been that's still
fairly fresh right yeah it's not even in
my bolt I think because it's so new it's
hard to say like what do people I can
apply I have stats to tell you yeah I
love about it were you prepared I
prepared a piece of paper because I I
didn't want to go digital I wanted to go
offline for this this was my present
that's also your problem prep Oh prep
pro it's misleading we're not talking
about amazing internals at all but I
just figured I thought you'd think I was
cool that I had this it is apparently
there's a lot of them there's not a lot
sorry
so I'm cool you are cool for real
empyrion and real Jack I think because
it's so new it's like okay any any the
end dates were gonna rip off to
rebalance it they're all probably
happening by the time this video goes
live I'm not sure but today on Wednesday
January 8th we are working like I just
came back from iPhone on what the first
hotfix of the year is gonna be so at the
time of talking we have not put out the
first 2020 hotfix which really sets the
pace for how people will perceive what
our priorities are and what we're gonna
address quickly what's gonna sort of
wait until we have more data and the
fundamental thing in all the squad's
I've joined and all the feedback I've
read is holy [ __ ] this is fun and then
there's like a button but it's buggy or
but it's to grindy but because the korg
gameplay and like the coordination and
everything is always being upheld and in
the butts are things that you can kind
of fix better and quicker than a core
gameplay loop I'm very optimistic that
the 2020 year is gonna bring some pretty
crazy fun [ __ ] because it seems hey some
things I've read is it's the it's so
good but what are some of the things you
learn from this feedback you said this
is from one specific survey yeah so
holidays were coming Steve put out this
survey of like hey guys 2020 is coming
and you know what can you tell us about
warframe generally speaking I mean never
really have done surveys like that
scary it is and it was fun though with
28,000 people replied of the 28,000
people we asked them on a scale of 1 to
10 how was your 2019 year with warframe
8 was the average so 8 into 10 for
20,000 people yeah not bad you lie to me
well there's three pieces of data we can
use in there we can use mean median and
mode so the mode and the median were
eight so 50% of the countries went eaten
but we're gonna show all the raw data
later this month I'm gonna check it and
the mean so the average average was
seven point two five so good for 20,000
people yeah pretty good so you know it's
just like kinda you it's a good spot to
be in obviously the greatest would be
like a perfect game you can't really
take that seriously for folks like oh
it's perfect because anyway no it's not
just like yeah just like good lying
you're lying to me yes or Steve Judas -
exactly but see I have a wire exactly I
kept the stats and I was like Steve get
out of here you've moved kind of Daniel
visit I did and then when we asked
people one thing people said you know
what was your favorite thing we did this
year empyrion so we did what was your
favorite what was your least favorite
and generally speaking what was your
most negative issue with warframe so
when it came to so negative so for what
was your least favorite thing we did in
the year Coolidge's did win that so 39%
of people voted koopa witches was their
least favorite
so 61% of people kind of split out
across melee empyrion and other
categories there so suppose we're
watching who might not know kou villages
are like a cool like essentially they're
your personalized like kind of
procedurally generated based on your
actions enemies like villains nemec's
but it's interesting because back in
2014
shadow of Mordor release it's like oh
this is the game that everybody's gonna
try to mimic but then not many people
did if any it was exciting to me it's
because I play a lot of warframe and
shadow more towards one of my favorite
games the last like decade yeah what
were people's what do you think people's
problems were with it was it the
grinding grind and rng was the biggest
issue and it always is it's eight years
now of having a game that only is
sustained by its grind in rng so it's
like you need it there but how do you do
it in a way that and again so people
love most about working this action in
combat so it's really like how do you do
grind in repetition but keep the action
in combat high because the most things
people love most about war
frame of the options we gave action in
combat mm-hmm the grinder repetition so
you always those are like the eternal
good and evil that are fighting it yeah
not to say that grinding repetition are
inherently evil like it's crazy because
like Pokemon just came out and people
are farming shinies and like you look
and you're like you're literally
grinding against like a 2% Oh people are
rubber people to breed pokemon and hatch
the hatch eggs are like rubber banding
their analog sticks to walk around like
Skyrim sneak is all rubber band but not
actually not true I'm not here point of
the tangent being how does RNG and grind
work in a game like Pokemon versus a
game like warframe and what are people's
thresholds for it the hindsight we have
from last year is you know do aid don't
start years off with whiteboards because
then you're setting yourselves up for
timelines that you just don't know if
you can hit so I think like the broad
lesson is properly setting expectations
and the actionable lesson is just
communicate more of what those
expectations are
[Music]
realistically when you look at 2020 for
warframe it's like okay we injured 2019
in the face of the most intense
competition we've ever had as a product
like ever so when you say that like what
would it be like like you've just
basically the looter shooter game in
2019 got flipped over you had like I'll
say games directly cuz people will
obviously say in the comments like when
you have anthem Borderlands 3 and
destiny to go free-to-play in one year
and then your warframe you're just kind
of like sitting there like hey we've
been here for a while but those games
are really really really good so like
you you never want to give a proposition
to someone that's a warframe pan that's
like oh it's our time or like that's not
how we are so it's just about doing
things that make sense for a person who
plays a video game to enjoy what they're
doing without feeling like they're being
punished for yeah not playing speaking
of competition a lot of the times a lot
of stuff I've been focusing on last year
when covering warframe and a lot of the
stuff that I think a lot of people
because it's like an older game that's
been doing so many things right
what are is there anything that you can
point to from competition that the team
was like oh maybe we could implement
that and if it's not specific is there
anything that you personally like that
other games are doing like yeah this may
come as a surprise but when fortnight
did they're like event that like
destroyed the world and we used to do
[ __ ] they're very good at that I know we
used to do that and everyone on our team
saw there was like what happened like we
blew up relays and like we did all this
crazy and world [ __ ] that like changed
the world forever and then you know like
like we want to bring that idea back
that it's you know like this is a live
system that you're in and it's not just
stagnant
are you guys getting to the point now
where I mean you could have done
warframe to like three years ago if you
wanted to two or three years ago if you
wanted to game is a surprise to me that
grinding Gear pronounced Pat of Exile to
yes and they've already started updating
one to sort of flow into two whenever
that releases yeah yeah this is the
first time when more than like four or
five games in the broader landscape are
having that questions like do we even
need a sequel I don't think we do and I
don't think we should could
the question will be like what happens
when people get to mastery rank 30 on
their account right like that's sort of
like the ultimate sign that like you've
played warframe to the top and like is
that one working too you come soon I
don't know item it'll probably happen
this year so mastering 30 but in regards
to a sequel what that means I don't know
I don't want to add a two to it I don't
see how we could that might be good if
you weren't growing maybe that like
reignite excitement grouse doesn't seem
to be a problem for you there's a
expression that we're kind of like the
theme park right you know people get
their ticket they come they check out
the new ride and they leave or they stay
and enjoy everything yeah so we're kind
of either building new attractions for
people to come check out or we're
redoing the old ones because they're
starting to you know show some wear and
tear and this is the first console
translation for warframe ever but I mean
we were a launch title on ps4 so what
our future holds on PS 5 and on the Xbox
series X remains enough to be seen I'm
super excited if we get a chance to be
on them what do you do with warframe
like at this point I think everyone I
want my account progress here and there
so if we had another console in the
console family didn't make us what
happen so I'm just like thinking right
now about our database cinema no can you
talk at all about I mean I know one
thing a lot of people are asking for is
like cross save yes and I know didn't
put a lot of pressure on you when Bungie
implode early were they like oh they're
doing it well I think I read their fine
print about everything as like more
detailed I'm like how did they do this
like how did they do it not only
technically but you know what are the
limitations right like it's not like
free saves between it was like you take
it one way or not like it was like we
did the one way transfers for a limited
time only and we only ever allows you to
go from PC origin situ to console
partner XYZ there's reasons we can't go
from console to the other one and if you
could get around that if you're you know
a different developer or publisher how
did you do it there's a lot that we have
to do to recreate what that did for
their community which was it brought
people together on places they couldn't
sure so she got new more mm-hmm that
like it's definitely 2020 oh yeah and if
it's not if December comes in this video
still live in new or is it aired on 2020
yeah you can use
it okay to just okay great in the
jugular I have your permission yes okay
okay her dad saw that some new Worf
managing expectations and figuring out
when you want to make things public when
you want to keep it secret etc
fundamentally we are trying to entertain
the same people that may have been
playing the same game for eight years so
how we do that is going to can it's
never gonna get easier so we're doing
our best to achieve that which is why
things like Imperium come along because
it's like let's just do a whole totally
new thing and yeah it's just we'll just
keep trying Mack well thank you so much
Rebecca there you go we're stopping by
enjoy your rest of your time in New York
I will and good luck with the rest of
the year I'm sure I'll see you yes there
was my threat of my death at the end of
this year so I have to take this
seriously oh yeah I know your words not
mine